hey guys before we get into this episode
we wanted to ask you to help us out with
something now last week we told you
about our listener survey at pod survey
calm slash biscuits and first of all
thanks to those of you who have already
filled out out that survey but if you
haven't already we still need your input
it's quick anonymous and it helps us and
you right we're able to provide your
biscuits to you for free at no charge
that's what free means thank you because
of our sponsors but we want those
sponsors to be things that you actually
care about and this survey will help
make that happen yeah go to pod survey
comm slash biscuits it'll take no more
than five minutes and your answers will
help match our show with advertisers
that best fit the sensibilities of our
podcast and its listeners you when you
play the survey you'll be entered in an
ongoing monthly raffle to win a $100
Amazon gift card you know what we could
get on Amazon for $100 I can think of a
number of things but you're gonna get
them we're not gonna get them you're
gonna get them like a number of q-tips
and yeah make several dozen at least we
will not share your email or sell your
email address to anyone and we will not
send you an email unless you win so go
to pug survey always want to say
podcasts it's not but don't do that
don't go there go to pod survey comm
slash biscuits yeah either go there
right now
pod survey comm slash biscuits or did I
don't know write it down and go there at
the end addition right cuz you know you
can we want you to listen to any or
biscuit so if you're not gonna go right
now take an ink pen right on yourself
you could tattoo it later or you can
just do it on a little note however you
take notes do it you'll find it later
and be like oh what am I supposed to do
oh yeah it was a good a pod serve a.com
slash biscuits thanks thanks for being
your mythical best on with the biscuit
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett joining us today at the roundtable
of dim lighting is us it's a retinal ink
only air basket so no buttons join us
we're joining each other here on link
join me right here at the roundtable for
a discussion about sports and our
interactions with said topic
yeah just for our lives yeah
to clarify this just before you tune out
if you're not interested in sports this
isn't like hey let's talk about the
Yankees you know or the Superbowl where
we can't do that
this is capable we're talking about us
and how we've interacted with sports
throughout throughout the years so now
that you understand we're going to be
talking about ourselves
now you can tune out yeah and to make an
informed decision to exact this kit
that's what it's called yeah when you
when you when you get out early your d
biscuiting I will say I'm not too active
at sports these days last time I kicked
a soccer ball was over the holidays
though because I was staying with my my
sister and brother-in-law and my two
nephews and I was outside in the yard
with the soccer ball and the
neighborhood kids came and joined me and
me and like eight other neighborhood
kids where your nephews outside too or
were you just out there with a soccer
ball if at first one of them was out
there and then it was just me and all
the neighborhood kids and it was one of
those things where I had a soccer ball
and I was like you guys think I can kick
it through that tree there's a tree that
had like a y-shaped in it you guys think
I'm trying to impress a bunch of kids
basically as where I was do it you guys
think I can kick it and I always do this
because if you do it on the first try
they never forget it 45 minutes later
even though they don't know you you'll
be like that mythological guy that was
at their neighbor's house who kicked the
soccer ball through the V in the tree
yeah right when his first try it makes
I'm gonna remember that the rest of
their lives is what you're thinking oh
this is more revealing do you remember
what it was like growing up there are
things like this that you remember okay
then a stranger comes out of a house and
kicks and amazing I mean if you're
wearing a cowboy hat maybe or like
there's something else a little weird
about you I'm tall okay okay and this is
a familiar concept but hold on but you
didn't even know because I thought after
45 minutes in every kid in the
neighborhood no the concept is familiar
before you tell me what happened oh the
concept of setting up a physical
challenge like this is familiar to me
because you did it our whole lives you
we'd be walking down the street before
we had our licenses you'd be like just
pick up that rocket
I bet you I can hit that the oh in that
stop sign from ru hundred yards away
well think about it spin the next two
hours trying to do and what happens when
you do it it changes your luck super and
everyone around you and so what happened
well 45 minutes later I did it for 45
minutes in the front yard kicking the
soccer ball with strange kids well I did
it and every kid did it and then
eventually I kind of got tired the with
a mom from one of the houses came out
and started talking I talked to her for
a while the kids tried it and then I
went back to trying to eventually I got
it and I'm sure those kids lives are
changed so that was your recent where
was the last time you kicked a soccer
ball huh I do have a soccer ball on my
garage but it we got it out the other
day it was like totally flat it had died
the soccer ball well you can revive it
pretty easily you know to perform a
miracle you can just like get a pump
that's a good point but I wasn't I
wasn't willing to do that so that you
just took my temperature on organized
sports right there you know here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna take a trip
down memory lane with our involvement in
organized sports I think there's lots of
places that we can go some sad some
happy yeah and see if there's any
lessons to be gleaned that I think
ultimately may apply to us as dads maybe
and having kids and their involvement or
lack of involvement in organized sports
but first I want to talk about underwear
for a second oh really
well yeah I can always talk about
underwear and you guys know that we like
to talk about me undies but since we're
talking about sports I'll go ahead and
relate it to my high high school soccer
coach Coach Randle never wore underwear
how do I know this because he always
wore like soccer shorts in some days
they were white and they were old oh man
we're see-through dude really and yeah
my first as a freshman i sat the bench
and where is the bench it's behind the
coach so I'm like looking at his behind
where you should be watching the game
well I'm like put me in coach so I don't
have to look at your behind through your
see-through Umbro shorts
the dude needed underwear well I think I
like to think that he never worn away
because he couldn't find the perfect
pair link what did he need he needed to
know about me undies
me undies are the most comfortable
underwear you will ever wear I'm wearing
a black pair right now and yesterday I
was wearing a camouflage I'm wearing a
red pair wearing a red pair just in case
I'm in an accident you won't know it
like if I'm shot in the butt like if
your groin is bleeding that's horrible I
mean I don't know what could happen man
this is Los Angeles but I will say one
of the things I love about me undies is
they are environmentally friendly
materials used or sustainably sourced
from the Austrian Alps so think about
this link I've never been to the Alps
never been to that part of the world to
be honest with you but we're not give
easy when I exactly when I put these on
I feel like a mountaineer I feel like
somebody in the outside doing one of
those calls what do they do
yodel like a yodel I can't really do it
yodel so anyway if you can get that
mental picture of me on top of the
mountains in my underwear looking good
they use a carbon neutral process so
there's a low carbon footprint they also
save water and energy to their spun
dried fiber process so you feel good
wearing me undies and you feel good
about wearing them they got cool styles
for both men and women they all look
great and here we're gonna make it easy
go to me on DS comm slash rhett and Link
and get 20% off your first order and
free shipping save even more when you
buy a pack of them they guarantee you're
gonna be happy with them or your first
pair is free and once you feel me at
ease on your body you're never going
back alright to get that 20% off make
sure you go to me on DS comm slash rhett
and Link I think it's gonna become
pretty clear as we take this trip down
memory lane that I know for me it's
gonna be a case study in anxiety so I'm
gonna go ahead and throw that out there
that's what Sports has meant to me over
the years so and I'm ready to unpack
that a little bit and I will say that
sports more or less defined my childhood
definitely my adolescence hmm in a lot
of ways well growing up in a time of
place we did so in a little town of
Buies Creek North Carolina and I'm
trying to figure out what what year this
was I mean we're talking the late 80s
being like starting to get into
recreations
every mid to late 80s everybody you know
if you were a kid it was automatic you
were expected to play recreation sports
and the biggest one in Buies Creek was
soccer baseball was big but it was
interesting how big soccer was I think
it was the start of that recreation
soccer boom but I started playing from
like seven years old oh yeah
so maybe even before I met you you know
yeah I did not play you know we moved to
North Carolina in 84 I did not play
soccer when we lived in California but
you know it's interesting because we
both got involved and we were both on
the same team we had a weird thing going
because I'm a little older than you
there were the same year in school so we
were be on a sober my birthday's the
next June right so we'd be on the same
team one year and then I would age up
yeah and so there was this alternating
thing but guys the first coach that I
remember is Tony oh yeah
coach Tony I can't remember his last
name right now but he was this very
charismatic super friendly awesome guy
he's black guy with jheri curl
yeah he had a jheri curl at a time when
I mean it was like I guess it was a
little bit out of she was a dying art
form but it was still it wasn't just
like crazy unacceptable at that point it
was just like oh this is still almost in
style we never thought anything of it
no I mean but it was very much like Sam
Samuel Jackson and Pulp Fiction yeah but
it also had a mullet built into it I
remember that specifically a jheri curl
that went into a mullet and he called me
link sausage well of course it's
creative so he and he had nicknames for
everybody so that was a good first first
exposure to organized sports for me I
but I mean I like soccer I think it was
when I got into baseball that it started
to get into problems but you had some
problems on the soccer field right yeah
well like social problems well now this
is actually you may have heard and let
me just give it a little disclaimer here
we're gonna we're gonna tell a number of
stories on the show this week and we're
probably going to tell some stories that
you may have heard if you've been
listening to us in the various forms
that we have told these stories in the
past we've been doing this for a long
time so we may end up repeating some
things but so but
you know you're gonna hear them in their
proper context so the first fight I ever
got in was at the recreational soccer
field which I might add was sloped at at
least 10 degrees I mean this thing was
so sloped and we played sideways on it
so if you kick the ball straight towards
the goal it would roll down the hill out
of bounds yeah you had you had to that's
why they started bending soccer balls
you know like Bend It Like Beckham to
counteract the slope and the boys creek
field it originated there on her field
but there was a guy John Carson shoutout
to John Carson I don't know where you're
at don't even know if you're still alive
hope you are but John Carson was on our
team he was a big guess a big guy and
let's just I don't remember him being a
nice guy he was a jerk I'm sure he's
nice now if he's still alive right man
he wasn't nice what he was annoying was
a lot he was not a nice guy back when he
was a kid but they you know lots of kids
had issues and weren't very nice but we
were friends at the time and John Carson
was picking on you and we were in doing
that drill where you're standing in a
line I don't know exactly what you
learned in this drill but they set the
ball up at the top of the box and you
just run up there one at a time and kick
it in no goalie can you kick it in an
empty goal that's the skill we all need
to know you gotta set the bar somewhere
but we're standing there and John Carson
starts making fun of you I honestly
don't remember what he was saying but I
don't I don't remember any of this by
the way but I'm except through you
retelling it and he was picking on you
and you weren't doing anything about it
now we've established before that you're
not you're not a meek individual these
days but as a child you were and so you
didn't do a lot of standing up for
yourself well he was three times my size
- he was pretty slow though but I was
big you know I was tall at least yeah
that wasn't big around but I was tall
and I just I remember the only thing I
remember is just looking at him
and punching him the first punch up ever
thrown I ever threw and I push him in
the gut right in his stomach and he was
a rotund fellow do you remember saying
anything to him before you know it
lately caught him off guard that's the
call a sucker punch sucker punch
riding the stomach it's sunk in into his
I remember the light-blue Buies Creek
uniform oh yeah and then pop right back
out and he just got this look on his
face it was like a delayed reaction and
he just sort of looked at me and he put
his hands on his stomach and then he
walked away and he sat down he never
made fun of you again Thank You Rhett I
and he still doesn't make fun of me now
no he doesn't and just think he'd
probably be here right now at the table
pologize making fun of me if you hadn't
a punched him back then he'd still be
here he'd be like the monkey on my back
making fun of me constantly you know
think about how my life would be
different I doubt that's true
um you talk about those jerseys if you
can go to my house right now
I have all of my Buies Creek Jersey not
surprised and you know I was I was
number five or number 55 and I kept them
in Lando sleeps in him now I mean soccer
was an important part of my wanted to be
5 or 55 yeah that was my lucky number 5
so I get you know you got to choose your
number and I always try to choose what
five in it interests Tom and I kept all
of them and now he's Lando sleeps in
them and as he continues to get a little
older he can sleep in the large ones
because I they get bigger as I got older
and I I just somehow kept him because it
was special to me that time of my life
even though I didn't particularly enjoy
it enjoy it soccer stay with me now
baseball as I said on the other hand was
not good I'm I I distinctly remember
being a Yankee you were on this team
we're in the black and gray outfit and
outfit go to uniform yeah we call it a
uniform where I'm from yes you're from
King crow as a coach and I could not hit
the ball I cannot fine I could not keep
my eye on the ball so I just remember
swinging and there's so much anxiety
because everyone's looking at you trying
to hit this ball it's not like soccer
where the ball goes to you and then you
hit of somebody else and then it comes
back and you kick it yeah there's a lot
of focus on there's a lot of focus
people are actually saying batter batter
better that you if you're the bad I
could not focus on the ball I figured
out if I get beaned if I get hit with
the ball by the
pitcher because we had a pitcher by this
point you get on first base and the only
way I got on base no exaggeration the
entire season was by getting beaned come
on but this is a ball this is a bold
move I mean I would I would stand really
close to the plate so that I would get
beaned that's pretty sad isn't it well
it's just cuz I would swing and it would
be like guessing on a test I I never
understood that I could actually watch
the ball fly out of the pitchers hand
and then make contact with it with the
bat like I never learned how to do that
and I just thought his most as lucky as
everybody most kids are scared I was
even scared of the ball I didn't like
them that hard ball going by me like
that I was frightened of it it had long
arms like I was more I was more afraid
of the embarrassment of striking out I
struck out so much that I got fed up and
then I was like bring it on hit me hit
me
I got I'm wearing a helmet I don't
recall this just did this ever work did
you kill I've never discussed it with
anyone I just did it yeah yeah I got on
base and sometimes I would get in a
second base I don't recall ever getting
a home base I wasn't good at any aspect
of this sport but I remember in the
outfield
I would I would they put me in what
which is the one where they don't hit
the ball to you right field is the least
likely that's we play that's where I was
and I literally prayed to God that they
would the ball would not be hit to me
like if you if you like had spy glasses
and you looked at me on the outfield
you'd see my lips moving like that's how
strongly I felt about baseball I did not
want you know I didn't want to be put on
the spot well it's interesting no
confidence I feel like I had the strong
feelings also as strong feelings as you
did to not be embarrassed and all this
but the way I didn't want to be
embarrassed is by not succeeding not
doing something it wasn't necessarily oh
don't hit me the ball just like if they
hit me the ball I better catch it but it
wasn't praying I don't get the ball hit
to me yeah I just didn't I didn't want
to pass the test I didn't want to be
tested now you said Ken crow
go to coach and there was another guy
that was with him there was a pair of
guys that came in late they came in
like in the in the night and then they
left again you know like Tony was there
for years bin Ian's or also coaches for
years King crow and this guy they were
in for like a year and they were gone
but did you know the other thing that
they I just remember this as we were
kind of thinking about this today the
other thing that Ken Crow and this other
guy did was karate that he seemed like a
military guy they got a crew-cut cred
red hair red hair crew cut you know
those guys are always into martial arts
right he didn't teach me karate I didn't
take that well I might would have
excelled at no they said they said
karate is being taught and I was like
well I need to learn how to do that I
got a defend blank against joggers so I
went and took the class and I remember I
made it to yellow belt which you know
most of you right now that's not real
far that's like a couple of weeks maybe
okay but the thing that happened is you
got to understand we come from Buies
Creek North Carolina a very conservative
part of the country and Ken crow started
talking about like the mindset of karate
like getting into like the dragon and
stuff getting into the trash I don't
even remember what it was about all I
know is it kind of got into some Eastern
philosophies and at that point kids
started talking to their parents about
this dragon fellow King Carl had to fly
next thing you know King crow was gone
oh and they stopped with the yellow bow
we don't want to know about this this
Eastern stuff unless it's Eastern North
Carolina barbecue you know so King crow
came in he left with King crow if you're
out there if you're still high this is
you know what we should just stop the
whole thing about whether now they're
still alive right but you know because
what if they're not right then they well
they're not listening something for
what's true and so it's like talking to
no one here it is who's here we should
just drop the whole bit there's lots of
people who are listening we should
probably talk to them yeah we should
when did you get into basketball I got
into basketball you know on my own we
had a basketball goal at home even when
I was in California and then we had a
basketball goal that my dad took pains
to build on the road you need to
remember this we landed on the dead end
and he just built the basketball goal on
the road so I played with my brother
there was no opportunity to play there
was no rec league back until we got into
middle school yeah
and that was coach royal who is our
history coach and PE coach was your
basketball set history coach how long
was a year to war of 1812 come on answer
me now he was that he was a history
teacher but he was a PE coach yeah he
was Rock Island Beach yeah that's you
but he was the basketball coach and he
was the soccer coach now the thing I
remember about coach Royal with coaching
soccer in middle school was you would
goalie I was and I was a defensive man
and if he got mad at us during a game he
would clear the bench and he would do
this in basketball too but in soccer
there's 11 people on it yeah that's me
but he would take the whole team out he
didn't take me out I will say but cuz
there was no other goalie because the
goalie has like gloves and you know it's
we have to change the goal he would take
10 of us out then and bring in the 10
people who were on the sidelines like
the Signet strategy and just to prove
rush legs to call that fresh less to
prove the point that we sucked and we
needed to be out of there and then of
course they would we would start losing
because we would be decimated by the
bench yeah and he and he did this very
same thing in basketball he also had a
thing that he did when he got really
upset at PE but also in basketball where
he would thinking throws the ball at the
backboard
Oh like trying to break it we would all
be sitting there and he would throw the
ball he would be standing like at the
3-point line me with and he would just
throw the ball at the backboard and it
would bounce back and him catch it what
wow that was impressive and that was the
whole point
did he ever kick a soccer ball through a
Vienna tree then probably the point was
not to scare us the point was to impress
us and let me tell you I don't know if I
can do this
yeah right and so he adopted the same
strategy for basketball but the thing I
remember about my eighth grade year of
basketball was now you know anything
about Buies Creek you know
that's the home of Campbell University
of the fighting camels the colors are
orange and black and the gym where the
camels played was you know like a 9-iron
away from the where with the demons play
we were the demons the ps3 demons blue
and gold blue and gold demons in the
whole court of course is blue and gold
well one year coach role comes in he
says guys I am very excited to let you
know that this year we have new uniforms
mm and you know what they are the
Campbell University uniforms so you know
at this point you don't know what to say
couple of things to note a these were
University uniforms for people who are
in college and we were in sixth seventh
and eighth grade okay oversized so
they're a little big and I was a big guy
so I actually got one to fit but half of
the guys had this universe was falling
off of him now it was like 1988 or
whatever it was so the shorts were still
really short but it's really big and
we're playing in these orange and black
or really orange they were orange with
black riding but they said Campbell on
them so we got some moms to get this
black they actually printed Buies Creek
on a black t-shirt and then cut the
black t-shirt out in a square oh wow a
rectangle and sewed that onto the
uniform so we played in oversized orange
uniforms that had Buies Creek sewed over
them we played on a blue and gold court
that was eighth grade for me which made
my vantage point as the official
scorekeeper of the girls middle school
they didn't get those uniform made my
vantage point it seemed like I was in
the right spot I did not have to wear a
uniform at all I could wear anything I
wanted I got into the games free which
is why I became the scorekeeper and then
I cuz I wanted to be able to not pay to
get into the guys games that I could go
to the away games and how did you get
roped into this I volunteered I was like
you know I would you go with stats
I'm good with I'm good with pencils and
I'm good with numbers and I'm willing
and no one else wants to do
did you was there a girl on the
basketball team that you were in sure
no I I wanted to see the I wanted to
watch the basketball games without pain
and I also got to drop I was like $1 to
get in I got to travel with the
basketball team to the away games and be
involved okay was your way of being
involved be involved you know I didn't
want to be a loser because again it was
in middle school if you didn't play
sports okay then you did nothing
it wasn't yeah it wasn't like well you
me and drama or I was in band this we
didn't we didn't have drummer theater
they would have that until high school
but did you okay so and I didn't want to
keep score from the guys game cuz I just
wanted to watch it so I kept score for
the girls and am I talking are we talkin
down to the the minutiae like rebounds
per person like well no because you were
keeping the score of the game because
that was a person that was hitting the
buzzer and stuff I was he had a little
pet I was keeping score by player and
assists
what about rebounds and fouls rebounds
huh no but I didn't have capacity for
that you didn't keep it with rebounds I
did that's like how did you know when
somebody had a double-double
we didn't maybe we did I don't I'm
pretty sure we weren't keeping up with
rebounds then you you shouldn't have
been doing that and coach Rose daughter
Elizabeth she kept score it was a team
thing keep score kept up with the
rebounds right she keeps going for the
other team by us to keep the other team
honest yeah okay and what's cool cuz we
got to meet the really cool people from
the other schools namely the score
keepers from those schools not the
that's the cream of the crop that's the
top of the social because we had our own
little identity it was cool did you get
free popcorn you remember the popcorn
machine no I didn't get free popcorn but
you do remember the popcorn machine they
would break that sucker out oh yeah
every basketball game and when I think
about that that time in my life I smell
popcorn in like locker rooms what does
the opposite happen though when you
smell popcorn do you start like want to
do layups I don't know that's a good
question right and bring some hot corn
in here that's probably a no like when
you go to the movie theater you don't
like want to put on your fighting camels
uniform but you okay so then of course
after middle school we've got high
school and
high school was a bit of a breaking
point for me not breaking away probably
the it was a turning point is the word
that I was looking for because it was a
time in which I began to seriously
consider but hold on you did break
something I did and I'll get to that in
a second I began to seriously consider
am I going to be a basketball player
yeah well I mean you're so tall and I
had a goal in front of your house am I
gonna play college basketball and maybe
beyond that like is this gonna be what
my life is and and starting my freshman
year and really moving in my sophomore
year it became a thing where as we
talked about before on your biscuits and
in the context of another story I would
spend hours every single day during the
summer when we weren't playing during
the year
practicing those shoes strength shoes
the shoes that had a special platform on
them the big ball which is an
extra-large basketball that my dad
bought that gets you better with a
regular-sized basketball so if the ball
was it would still go through the hoop
but it was bigger than normal just 1.5
times the size of a regular called the
big ball so then when you when you use
the regular ball it was just like no
this is so easy at the ball smaller
which it doesn't make a lot of bein in
the ocean yeah right like it may be and
but I was I would do the AAU team thing
during the summer and you know and
because my life was sort of bent towards
doing this and I took it very seriously
now this get to get back to what I did
break I took this very seriously this
responsibility to be a basketball star I
took it very seriously
and my dad would film the game so that
we could send them off to potential
colleges for recruiting right and this
is by like junior year and I think that
this is probably caught on tape but
hopefully that tape is gone but we were
playing at Triton remember Triton the
big rivalry sure to rival to harness
central and it's close game and coach
gage takes me out of the game
I may have made a mistake or got a foul
or something like that but it was like a
crucial time of the game he takes me out
of the game and I
look at him and I just kick the bottom
of the bleachers I was there I remember
seeing you goat to the back to the bench
and it from my vantage point again this
it was I would describe it as a tantrum
yeah I was pitching a fit you kicked the
bleacher I kicked the bleachers and then
I sat down and as I sat down as I did
something I've done something I've done
something to my toe but of course a
couple minutes later is like right get
back in there I get back in there and
I'm hurting I'm having trouble getting
around but I'm like we got to win this
game I think we actually lost I think I
missed a shot at the end for a chance to
win it's it's a sad story but after that
game I was like to have my toe really
hurt she said we'll take you to the
infirmary tomorrow you know we could go
to the infirmary on campus at Campbell
because it worked there because he
worked there for free and they take and
they take you to keep your shoe on until
then
or did you take my shoe off that night
took it off I took it off and it was a
little bit swollen but it wasn't black
and blue but long story short I had
split the bone right down the middle
the big toe bone now it just drank twice
yeah lengthwise it had cracked but it
was still intact and that's why it
wasn't like super super painful and I
ended up playing the rest of the season
they just put like a little weird thing
around it and you got you could go ahead
and tell him about your records or the
record because I know you want to oh I
wasn't even gonna share that but yes I
will say that unless it has been broken
this year and I don't think it has going
on 19 years now link I hold the
single-season a three-point record for
most three-pointers made in a season 77
my senior year I made now will say so
and you tie someone with number of toes
broken in a game problem right yeah 1-1
total toe somebody's probably broken
more that's true so don't on that one if
you're out there if you're playing
basketball at harness central I give you
every opportunity to beat that record
good luck but so I took this very
seriously but I was thinking there's
another story that involves both of us
which is an indication of how towards
the end of my time in high school we got
involved in other things we started a
band the wax paper dogs and they
we suddenly thought we were gonna be
rock stars and we were making videos
with that camera that your dad was
filming you for recruiting we would take
that right here so we thought we wanted
to be filmmakers or like rock stars
so your your commitment was waning it
was waning but we were still a really
good basketball team and I was still a
really good player and we were in the
state playoffs first round of the state
playoffs I can't remember who we were
playing but we were playing the team
that would go on to win the state
championship spoiler alert we lost the
game but here's what happened we you
gonna blame me for you losing the game
is that what this story is gonna be the
game was it that that night at like 6 or
7 o'clock right and of course school
gets out about 3 p.m. and this is senior
year so we both got our licenses we can
we can drive somehow all right now I'm
gonna say that this was your idea
ok we're like you know it was getting
warmer because it was like March you
know it wasn't even March because the
state playoffs would have been in
February was February but it was a
really warm day warm day in 50 when we
loved to swim in the river and so first
warm day of the year we haven't been
swimming in the river like all fall and
winter it's like well I think we should
go today to the Cape Fear River and swim
let's let's break that one open between
the game between the end of school and
the game yeah and let's not go to the
normal spot where we swim let's go to a
place that we've never been let's go up
the river into the woods and drive up to
the little creek that comes off of the
side of the river yeah so of the Cape
Fear River
let's not only go swimming let's get
lost first right and even though it was
warm the water was nowhere near
swimmable Cemetery in North Carolina and
I remember you know this is a story in
and of itself but we jumped in and the
water was so frigid that all the blood
goes to your vital organs and it moves
so quickly that you can no longer like
paddle with your arms or walk with your
legs you can't move your extremities
well I was standing behind you and you
jumped in thinking I was always gonna
jump in as 2 or 3 feet deep link
completely goes under there he is
completely submerged and then I just
jump in after him and here we are
swimming for our lives to make it across
to an
Island that was actually in the middle
of the river between this this Creek and
the river and we nearly died because I
could not move my arms to crawl out of
the water we expended we expended a lot
of energy just getting out of the water
and then for the man we got we yeah but
we made it across to an island no doubt
this was two hours later we were going
up this island crossing over successive
areas of the river these little you know
shoot offs of the rip off shoots of the
river and it was getting to the point
where we didn't have a watch and we
didn't have cell phones nobody had any
of that kind of thing no and no water by
the way or food or shirts because we
took those off before we jumped in we
finally make it back to the car at which
we look at the clock inside your truck
and realize I've got like an hour before
I've got to be warming up for the game
the state playoffs and so and then that
was when we had a little trouble getting
out of there right we're saying yeah
it ruined you you tried to back up we
had a little we're open you ruin your
speaker
anyway I expended all the energy that I
had built up for the day
trying to save my life in the river and
subsequently had a poor performance in
the state playoffs and I'll never
forgive you for the you would've but we
didn't I don't think we ever told
anybody that's where you'd been you know
it just looks a little sluggish
okay I'll own that one I think it you
know it might have set the trajectory of
our lives and careers we may not be here
if we had water we would have won that
game we would have gone on to win the
state playoffs would you I'd be in the
NBA right now water boy I could be a
scorekeeper for the NBA you could I mean
that'd be pretty sweet getting into the
NBA games for free you got to keep up
with rebounds though oh you really good
they probably just have a rebound guy
that can specialize that could be that
guy soccer for me in high school was
still the thing that was part of my
identity you know again I didn't want to
be in the drama club and I wasn't gonna
keep doing band so I was good enough at
soccer so I did that as a freshman they
had
hazing technique I guess is the only way
to describe it
where the upperclassmen would put all
the freshmen in their place and this is
before the days where bullying was such
a hot topic yeah
in hazing was I mean this basically
happened every school in America every
sport and you knew joining a soccer team
that at a certain point there was going
to be one day that you went to practice
and all of the upperclassmen were going
to haze you on the cross-country course
mm-hmm before every soccer practice at
the beginning of every soccer practice
was running the three mile cross-country
course so you run the three miles it's
like a rat a farm
around a farm and a couple of country
roads and then come back and have your
an hour and a half of like doing your
soccer drills while John Carson sat
there holding his belly no he was being
doesn't in the picture anymore and I
remember the day I remember we you know
you'd start the cross-country course and
upperclassmen a lot of them were better
runners than me and they would always be
ahead of me but then I noticed they were
all hanging back and come to find out
they went through a shortcut through a
field so that when we went the long way
around it was like a Western a scene in
western movie we're running on a dirt
road yeah and we come on Bros just like
every Western yeah I did have on
underwear and we were Imbros oh I was
thinking about coach Brando he wore
Ambrose with nothing all day I remember
running and kind of coming up a hill and
as I started to rise on the horizon I
saw all the upperclassmen lined up like
prepared for war across the dirt road
yeah but and I remember turning to a
couple of my friends see were freshmen
Michael gob I'm like this is it
today's the day this is the moment and
so I just can't you just kept running
you just run right you know the running
certainly slows to kind of like a trot
and then a walk we're just walking right
up to him say all right guys I don't
know what they're gonna do exactly if
they're gonna just like start pummeling
us or something and I think
it was Jody Yarborough oh-hoo-hoo
engaged with me and what that meant
specifically was turning me around and
giving me the most atomic wedgie I've
ever known possible in the history of
man did he pull it over your head that's
what we were doing that's what they were
doing to all of us it wasn't punching it
wasn't hitting it was so it was innocent
in a certain way that we were all
getting wedgies but he was giving me he
grabbed my underwear
from the back of my pants if he needed
to understand the anatomy of a wedgie
and then he just pulled and pulled and I
remember bouncing off the ground like a
foot off the ground every time he would
yank and he and it didn't stop just kept
going the wedgie went on forever until I
heard a huge rip it wasn't a fart it was
my pant it wasn't you again though it
wasn't your actual legs the actual body
coming apart growing coming apart like
your toe that would have been bad
it was the waistband of my underwear and
so then I somehow they liked it ripped
and then I turned around and he had him
in his hand coach laughing like he had
like scalp somebody like he scalped
somebody yeah kind of a thing yeah and
then he throws him in the dirt and then
I pick him up and I picked him up what
do you mean I picked him up they were my
underwear I picked him up but they were
ruined well I picked him up I mean I'm
not gonna litter and then any sure
that's what you think I didn't have
pockets and I I've ran the rest of the
way in with my underwear of my hand I
listen in that case my pride is on the
line I'm leaving the underwear in the
field and the farmer can take those and
use them as fertilizer well let me tell
you I still have those underwear you're
kidding I'm not kidding now okay since I
moved to LA I'm certain that I've thrown
them away but I know that when I went
home from college like back to my mom's
house and when I was gonna get married
and all that stuff I still had them and
I kept them as a keepsake as a keepsake
in a box with my this makes it even more
appropriate with my science olympiad
medals
in my science project ribbons and my my
ripped up your high school variance it
was a Russell it was a rite of passage
and it was it was in that box
that's that keepsake box and uh because
that's when I became a soccer player now
I know for a fact that while you may
have received this this punishment as
you matured in high school you became a
jerk mm-hmm and in this sense like you
became the guy on the soccer team that
the underclassmen didn't want to cross
when it came to this kind of thing yeah
not because I mean you're you were you
weren't a big guy you were about the
same size that you are right now yeah
but I was mean you were mean well I I
felt like you know if I endured that
then I get my turn as an upperclassman
to to inflict that same love that that
memory on someone else and like I said
it was meaningful to me but yeah I mean
I wanted my retribution and so I gave my
fair share of wedgies
it didn't go beyond that that was the
extent of it that was the extent of it
but and I you know what I will say I
think that if quote-unquote hazing was
limited to that kind of thing they
wouldn't be this big issue that it is
you know what I mean yeah it's it's the
fact that it's it's taken to places that
are just over the line and inappropriate
given somebody a wedgie I mean come on
now you know
let's out let's have a little fun here
but it's it's just it becomes abuse
right so I was a jerk but it wasn't you
know it wasn't anything like that and I
I did have my you know that wasn't my
only reputation I was I was also uh you
know I had my accolades I had well okay
I had the one game right I had over the
course of my soccer career I started
playing a little bit sophomore year but
junior year is is when I got I got some
points on the board first
you've been playing defense and I've
been playing the bench you didn't play a
lot but then when you did get to play
like those defense Charles Charles
was the left was the right wing and he
would get winded and so I would come in
off the bench and replace him and you
remember this game you were in the stage
I came to all the games I you know I
came to support my friend link as he
played and yeah I can tell you we sat
together all of us who were not on the
soccer team which usually was me and
like Chris Gardner and I like a bunch of
girls you know everybody else seemed
like was on the soccer team and you you
got in there and I will say that I wish
that these two things had coincided I
wish I had coincided with a period of
time in which my dad was the announcer
for the soccer games yeah but my dad got
fired from being the announcer for the
soccer games because all he would do the
entire time he was announcing is talk
about you whenever I was in the game he
would give running commentary of only me
he was like the linkster gets the ball
linka reno he did because it was when
the SNL thing was popular but he got
fired but he because he would also talk
about he would get coach Brent will put
you in how about putting the linkster in
he would give advice he's the announcer
he's supposed to be announcing like
special events and like the score right
so they fired him after a few games but
anyway about putting the linkster in
coach come on doe air coach those two
things didn't coincide but I do remember
this game they put you in and within
minutes of you getting in there it was a
corner kick and I remember thinking all
right I'm I'm on the far side of this of
this corner kid when this thing comes in
I just got a you know I'd anticipate be
ready I remember closing my eyes and
flailing my legs and I remember feeling
Oh more credit you gotta give yourself
credit on that I might the ball was
coming in and I was just like I'm just
gonna throw my my foot up there and it
made perfect contact with my left foot
which I'm right foot it and it just zing
right in there I first goal ever scored
in high school history by me and we went
nuts I also went nuts we went we were in
this in the stands we mean of course
there's not a lot of people there it is
a soccer game in North Carolina but we
were
going nuts because they put you in there
and you scored first score ever and I
was you would have thought that I'd
scored the winning goal in the World Cup
final like I was running around I didn't
take my shirt off but I was running
around and giving everybody five and
just like like you know just exultation
and then it was not three minutes later
but not three minutes later there was
you know we were we were pushing in on
the on the defenders and the ball eeks
through and there's like this a scrum I
would call it like people just kind of
scruffing around right in front of the
the goal line and the goalie didn't have
the ball he had it for a second then he
lost it and then I realized that the
ball is at my feet and I walked it into
the goal I didn't even kick it but but
nope when the last thing put the touch
it was your left foot oh yeah yeah I
walked in there my left foot it was like
I'm not even left foot in I've kicked
I've seen two girls with my left foot
the only goals you ever scored by the
way I never scored another goal but I
had those that was my that was my
accolade that was my game we were we
were freaking out two goals one game one
foot the off foot the left foot and I
went into celebration mode again and
I'll never forget Josh Young who was the
friend of mine in the forward at the
time striker you know we get back and
we're setting up after I scored that
second gone he leans over and he says
when you score a goal you should act
like you meant to do it I guess the way
that I was celebrating everyone could
see the look of surprise on my face as I
ran around like did you see that I
scored you know kind of a thing Josh
young funny story about him eighth grade
I'm playing baseball and I hit a triple
and he's playing third base and he was a
little guy he got super little when he
was in eighth grade yeah of course this
were playing against Andrew so I didn't
really know him and he's looking at me
and I say what are you looking at
he says I'm trying to figure it out he
was so sharp you know and I had nothing
after that you had
nothing I had no comebacks but you had
to stay in there on the base beside that
little guy got me he became a great
friend later a great friend okay yeah he
taught me a lesson yeah
when you score go act like you meant to
do it I never played soccer in high
school it was mostly basketball but I do
have a cross-country I was on the
cross-country team because coach gage
was the cross-country coach and so he
asked us to run cross-country as a way
to stay in shape in the offseason right
cross-country in my opinion is like
soccer without having to do any of the
soccer because I ran your course I got a
wedgie on it and then I got no wedgies
then actually I spent another hour and a
half doing the actual sport but so you
would just do the course and that was
your sport but to get away I want to
give you some perspective here of how it
actually do that because it wasn't that
difficult to run the 3.1 miles you know
the 5k but even during the meets the
competitive meets the parents would come
out mmm they would all sit in the stands
because you would finish the race in the
football stadium in the football stadium
football field you're not really a
stadium and go around that last 400
meter so everybody could kind of see you
and you come across the finish line
mm-hmm I was so concerned about how I
was coming across I didn't really care
about winning and you don't mean coming
across the finish line you mean how you
how I looked finishing so what I would
do is I would take off real fast
I'd get out there and be like this isn't
worth it you know what it was a fourth
trophy I would've said well I'm not here
because coach gage wants me to be out
here and I would end up walking during
the middle of the meet and they pretty
much let anybody on the cross-country
team so even when I would run and then I
would walk there would still be some
people who were kind of in the same pack
with me and then we baguettes well your
legs are so long your your walk gait
true it could by someone brought I can
keep up pretty quickly so we get to the
very end of it and I'm like here's the
part where we're coming in and we've got
the parents and everybody watching and I
would get right to the football field
and I would turn it on and I would just
sprint that last 400 meters and I would
past like 12 people black border guys
coming out of nowhere just just in that
just to give you some perspective that I
mean I'm not prescribing this but men
saying that you should do this yeah
because I was still like not Nene we're
new
to begin the front right but so what
where the spectators thinking what were
your parents thinking your parent he
finishes strong well it's it the if they
weren't your parents they didn't know I
never you starting they would probably
think that guy just that guy is amazing
he just showed up late he must have been
delayed if he if he had started the race
on time my dad would have been the gold
medal my dad knew exactly what I was
doing he says you're not running in the
middle and then you're running at the
end I wasn't impressing my dad he was
smart enough to know what
but that didn't change your approach no
I kept it for their whole season because
he never ran without stopping the one
other sport that I did play my senior
year was golf where there was a golf
team and the thing I had observed from
our friends who were on the golf team is
like these guys are never in class you
know golf season rolls around these guys
get out early then when they play a golf
match that day they it takes so long to
play golf that are gone all day I mean
this is this is the life and I like
playing golf so I wasn't very good at
golf but I was I knew Coach Coleman
Johnny Coleman Jimmy Coleman well enough
to kind of you know kind of talk my way
onto the team he was a father of a
friend okay so and they let me play in
one actual match because I would I was
always on the rotation squad which you
know you didn't get to play unless
somebody was hurt but you got to go and
kind of drive around but they let me
play and actually keep my score one time
and I can't remember which course were
playing at but we're playing at this on
a hole where there's this huge dogleg to
the right so far to the right that you
can actually drive over the whole dogleg
and drive straight from the tee to the
green if we can hit it a long way and
the one thing I could you mean you could
buy us the whole hole because it was a
shortcut yeah drive a shortcut and to
the green take the corner off yeah and I
all I could do was hit it a long way cuz
I was so tall and I could swing it
sounds like what I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna go for it maybe
I'll get a hole-in-one on a par 4 who
knows and we probably needed it coach
Coleman and the coach from the other
team we're standing in the tee box
behind us okay just off of the side of
the cart path it's kind of hard to
understand the visuals here but
basically what happened was is I aimed
to
towards the green that was basically on
the other side of some trees and I just
I absolutely ripped it when I hit it a
little bit too far to the left didn't
hit it far enough to the right and I hit
the sign for the whole pole it says like
Oh 10 like 3 feet in front of you know
it was like one tee box down in front so
you know probably 20 maybe 30 feet away
I hit that thing and I knocked the crap
out of this ball the ball deflects
directly back at eye-level
oh and goes right in between the two
coaches who were standing right next to
each other it went right between their
two heads and if it had have hit one of
them it would have killed him or it
would have seriously injured them man so
the the only is like the only
opportunity I ever had when that happens
what what do you say four is too late
well everybody started laughing and then
I just hit it I didn't go back and hit
it again and I just hit another ball
because I was obese you know I starting
to behind oh that's my golfing that's my
golfing peak no no records were set if I
had a killed one of the coaches or two
coaches in one that would have been a
record but that's where you learned
about tobacco yeah I was also this again
it gives some context here this is an
Eastern North Carolina I actually had my
first experience which with dip tobacco
from the golf team they did that on the
golf team they had meant they had mint
flavored tobacco you know you should try
this is that Jody Yarborough he was
probably he was probably partially
responsible but by the time I was
playing yeah I was a senior so it was
had been passed down you know they all
did it everyone make you sick
the the mint flavor wasn't as strong we
weren't doing skull out there at least I
wasn't
oh but yeah so I had a little a little
bit of a habit which sounds crazy for
people to hear that that like we did we
did dip but you gotta understand
everybody on the golf team was doing it
and I did it for a little bit and
realized this is this is a this is a
habit that needs to break so it didn't
last pass
season yeah that's good because you
don't really pull the ladies which I
guess you couldn't back in the day you
could maybe I you know I think I mean
after that in terms of organized sports
I mean what you know I did I certainly
wasn't gonna play soccer in in college I
did move to a defensive position where I
wasn't able to score with my left foot
by sheer flukes but it just wasn't my
thing yeah and and you let go of the
basketball thing yeah even though you
could have played basketball and said we
both went to NC State and kind of put it
behind us there was no more organized
sports for me since then I think I
played frisbee golf with Todd Smith in
college that can be organized by a small
group like we would we'd organize
meeting up and then we would play and I
should get back into that like that
there's I don't know if there's a course
around here but we never did like the
Ultimate Frisbee thing which was like
wait I played a little intramural
basketball and that kind of thing but it
was you know not a lot of sports
happened so for me it wasn't until we
had kids yeah that that sports started
become back into a picture part of our
lives again right um back in North
Carolina before we moved out here they
had intramural basketball you know I was
like okay Chrissy let's get let's get
the kids involved in that so Lilly got
involved in intramural basketball and
then the next year I mean she didn't
love it but she did it and it was a good
learning experience so the next year we
got Lincoln to do it and I guess let's
see I mean he was like the youngest team
so we're talking six or seven years old
so just getting started
and we get up that morning for the first
game and he's just upset he's refusing
to go I'm like well son I you know I
didn't want to push him too hard because
of all of my experiences but we could
you know we couldn't get him to
articulate why I didn't want to go and
then finally finally he's like we're
pants it's like what I want to wear
pants I don't want to wear shorts
because they had a uniform which it was
usually has shorts had shorts and a tan
top right that's Brianne he said coming
he was hung up on the shorts he would
not wear the shorts we said well you
won't wear pants he said yeah and so we
put him in some we didn't put him in
jeans we we had put him in like warm-up
pants and then he's like the only kid
out there who's constantly warming up
constantly warm as an excuse for
everything though I'm just warming up
oh the games started yet so he was the
kid out there in the warm-up pants and
that that solved it we never got to the
bottom of really what was going on
inside of his mind like it wasn't I mean
he was shorts now he went a whole season
as the warm-up guy he went a whole
season in just pants and we were fine
with that did he well don't know but
there was um and he was fine with not
doing well and then when he played
soccer like a year later he wanted to
wear pants for that too and we were like
you're gonna be too hot and we so we we
talked him out of that so we did get him
into shorts when it came to playing
soccer victory and then we moved out
here and there was there was no
basketball or no soccer for for for
either one of them there's they play
baseball in Encino it's like a big thing
but they just don't want to do it they
don't want to join a team I think it's
not knowing the kids and it's just
intimidating to kind of get involved and
I think from for me because there was
always so much anxiety especially with I
mean it was an anxiety with soccer too I
did I can say I never really loved it I
was just decent at it if it want to be
generous with the term but baseball I
was very anxious and so it's kind of
like well if you don't want to do it I
get that because I did it and I always
wished I didn't want to do it it's just
question I'm getting them involved in
something but well you know it's funny
because I almost felt there was more
pressure in North Carolina to get the
kids involved in something and also
because we had done all this stuff you
feel like well I feel like my kids
should be doing something athletic you
know I right and so we did the same
thing we same two things that you
mentioned in a different order we did
recreational soccer and then we did
basketball and this is
when this was just locked we didn't do
this with Shepherd Shepherds to young
soccer would lock it was this whenever
he got close to the ball made contact
with the ball he would look at the
sidelines I like it you like look at who
was watching him kind of like me in the
end of the cross-country course uh-huh
and we're talking like a three or four
year old out there and he'd get the ball
and he'd run and then he started looking
at the sidelines and you could tell he
was running in a way that he wanted to
look cool in the way that he was running
and then he would lose the ball because
you can't do that you can't do look cool
and keep the ball and I was like and I
were you telling it lock you got to be
focused on the ball and he was too young
to really articulate what was happening
but he was so focused on what people
were thinking about him that he was
incapable playing the game and then we
play basketball and I was actually the
assistant coach for the basketball team
I remember you got roped into that and I
had to wear my shirt tucked in and
talked about that on a good mythical
morning at one point but one of the
early good myth yeah yeah because they
told you add tell you got a shirt Tucker
man no I'm not that guy I don't do that
I'm the coach that keeps his shirt
untucked the way you got it we did this
is the standard here so I wore shorts
and I tucked my tee shirt into him which
is natin done that in years Wow but
anyway I was a coach assistant coach I
was okay as an assistant coach my son on
the other hand was not great at
basketball he didn't score and I
remember there being this thing inside
me that was like you know I'm a little
embarrassed I want my I want my kid to
succeed at this and I and I don't even
know why but it was all because of me
it was all because of my reputation and
wanting to seem like I've got a kid
who's athletic but that but that was the
end of locks like organized team sports
oh that was thing whenever you whenever
you found out that he couldn't score you
took him out no he didn't care he didn't
care about it he didn't want to do a
ball as a dad you can't do this it's one
of those things where if we're like luck
we've got to go out of town this weekend
you're gonna miss your basketball game
we'd be like oh great he didn't want to
do it yeah so but then when we moved to
California because things have changed
quite a bit we moved to California and
we move pretty close to a public pool
and Jesse's like you think we should
they've got like a water polo team and a
dive team at this thing you know what do
you think he should do I was like well
he loves to jump off of stuff he's
already broken his arm jumping off of
something he might as well land in water
yeah
and so we take him over there and and
let him jump a little bit off of the
board and next thing you know he's on
the dive team fast forward that so
that's like how long we've been out here
40 years four years so it's probably
three years so yeah we probably did that
about a year end so three fast forward
three years from that point and now he's
on like a legitimate dive team he
practices five times a week and is this
is this is a high level of investment
here and as soon as we finish this ear
biscuit I'm getting in the car with my
family and I'm driving through the
desert to Las Vegas to a dive me that
he's going to be in for two days no I
mean let me preface this he's ten years
old and we're as a family we're going
out there this diving has become this
thing that he is all about and it's so
weird because I never was able to do a
flip I couldn't do a flip never done a
flip off the diving board I've always
been big and unable to do that kind of
thing
I have no insight into this sport I
can't help coach all I can do is
encourage him and be there but he's
suddenly become like this is like the
thing he's like that I don't want to
dive in college I want to get a
scholarship and dive in college he's
really good at it yeah and he's good at
he's naturally is naturally good at it
and he and he's any self-motivated he
wants to do it so my sports have come
become is going to these diving in Vegas
do they dive into like a slot yeah they
do like coin and you like a pool full of
you can hit the jackpot you can that
sounds dangerous
I thought you're gonna say do they like
dive into like a really shallow body of
water and in charge people for it or
something like that but you went with a
slot joke yeah I didn't think of egis is
place take a 10 year old but I guess if
you put him in a speedo then it all
works out yeah well that's did you how
did you navigate the whole speedo thing
because he has wear speedo do you have
to tuck your shirt in
no the dads do not other so your but the
dads all have to wear speedos no they
don't all dads have to wear how did you
navigate the speedo with him was there
like didn't care at all he he the first
thing that he had to wear was what they
call jammies which is looks like biker
shorts they're you know tight but they
go down your leg okay but then it's
funny because there's this culture
within diving and it's like if you're
serious about this you wear the speedo
and so now lock will go to this to the
pool near our house the public pool and
he'll wear his speedo to go and dive and
he's like my guess status and I'm like
I'm like you're not self-conscious about
this he's like no dad because that's
what real divers do and he says and dad
by the way once you get up on the board
and you start doing all these crazy
dives everybody's like oh that kids
legit and he horsies can wear a speedo
so what about the shame conscious does
he have to shave the legs
well he's 10 so it doesn't have much of
a problem with that but I don't think
that divers have to shave the legs I
don't think I think that's a swimmer
thing I don't think it matters how
quickly you enter the water but you know
huh I don't know I maybe I don't know
why we'll find out about that I'm sure I
think you'll be shaving his legs and his
arms but why do you need that for diving
well exactly you see you need to be you
need to be doing your research and
thinking about this as a father you got
to know what he's getting into
well that's the thing because it's gonna
be like a biker man I went
frankeour shaved I remember the first
time we went to a dive meet and I was
like oh that's just what our weekends
are gonna be I don't want to do this I
want to be committed to this kind of
thing right but then the next thing I
know he's up there diving and there's
like another kid that he's competing
against on my own that kid Falls I'm
like I'm the competitive nature that I
have starts coming out and now I want
him to be as good as you can of this and
he's and he's he's kind of like I was at
that age so he's self-motivated I don't
have to tell him to take it seriously he
just takes it seriously on his own and
I'm a diving dad now but it's it's
interesting there's I mean there's
certainly it mirrors your experience a
little bit and that okay you found
basketball you were really good at it
your dad identified that and he started
he started laying the groundwork for you
to be able to play on a collegiate level
and so that conversation even though
he's only 10 like he started to say
and so and that's the way the people
around him talk - it isn't like hey luck
I something I don't tell him I do now
but I didn't start by saying hey this
could be you could do this to get a
scholarship he's ten I own that's too
early but at the team he's on in the
program he's in that's how they talk
about it and so he's just he's he's into
that he's in the he's on the right team
where that is an actual possibility yeah
given the type of training right that
he's doing now but from your perspective
I mean do you see it kind of being a
replay of your own situation and then
you know how do you navigate that as as
a dad kind of knowing how you and your
dad interacted with it and how you know
he was excited to enable that but then
at a certain point you had to break away
and say you know what I don't want to
play basketball in college you know so
how do you what's your approach well my
approach is I think about the way that
that you know and you asked me a
question when we did the first ever
rhett and Link only your biscuit he
asked me the question you know do you
resent your dad or whatever for how I
pushed you and and I answered the same
way I'll answer now and I don't because
I feel like there was something about my
personality and in what I needed I
needed to succeed at something like that
even if it was just something what some
people would consider is frivolous sport
I think it actually helps shape the way
I approach things you know and I I don't
I don't think this is necessary for
everybody I think it's healthy for every
kid to be involved in something you know
whether it's music or some kind of art
or sports or whatever it might be I
don't think it has to be sports but to
be getting better at something and
focusing on something it's something
that's difficult and something that
causes you to face fears and I think
that the diving thing is way more
strategic than basketball if it was for
me but like as I got better and better
at basketball and ice and I put work
into things and I saw results I said I'm
gonna commit this summer to getting
better at this and then the next year I
was that much better than all my stats
went up I think that that mentality is
something that it translates
it translates into the success that I've
experienced later in life you know being
able to be successful in college to have
a to be an engineer for a little bit
even though it was a short time to now
doing the things that we're doing I
think there's just a mentality of
working on something putting effort in
and then seeing the result yeah I think
it's and so it translates right I think
it also resonated with your personality
type so it was it was it translated and
it resonated you know or it translated
became resonated with you so those two
things that if he doesn't want to do it
if he if there's been a couple of times
where it because this is a difficult
thing this is a lot of time involved
it's been a couple of times where he's
kind of wavered a little bit and I'd be
like like have you you haven't been
doing this for long and I don't I in his
reasons for what he was upset about or
whatever weren't really to do with
diving it was some different issues I've
been like like I think if you quit right
now you would regret it
and he he's more into it now but if you
know what as he gets older and he
becomes more able to think about these
things for himself and to make all these
decisions and he's like I don't want to
do this I mean if he doesn't want to do
it we're not gonna make him do it
but as he's doing it right now I'm like
listen if you're gonna do this you need
to be as good as you can at it you need
to put the time in and my instinct is
that that is gonna translate into other
things and it is currently resonating
with him personally yeah and and maybe
your challenge as a dad is to not you
know to not to push him based on your
desires but to be sensitive to his I
think for me it's kind of the opposite
is am I not encouraging my kids to get
involved in in sports because I hated it
so much and it was always such a source
of anxiety for me so if they express
they don't want to do I'm like of course
you don't want to do it I didn't want to
do it either but there's certainly the
biggest challenge is not letting
ourselves get in the way of what our
kids need to be doing but there's also
finding the thing or the
things that resonate with our kids
because they're their own individuals
they're their own people and we want
whether it's you know there's benefits
from doing sports even if it's not their
thing so by the way I feel like Chris
and I are talking more intently about I
think we should make them join some sort
of a sports thing organized sports for
one at least one term just to see season
just to see maybe that maybe you should
one term but I think the bigger question
is getting them involved in a number of
things so that they can discover who
they are you know it's what resonates
it's not that I have to it might be yeah
it might be like I want to master this
musical instrument or it might be that I
want to paint or I want to draw or I
want to be I want to start making videos
or I just and we're certainly seeing
those things I think it you know I can
go ahead and shuck a number of those
boxes which aren't sports related but I
think it's interesting that we you know
we we came from a place to where those
balling thing that you could succeed in
with sports or academics and then in but
nobody think about a for a second though
in Buies Creek in 1985 1986 you were it
wasn't gonna be like I'm gonna be a
piano player like that wasn't an option
especially for a boy if you were a boy
it was and I'd say even a girl your
opportunity was I'm either gonna be I'm
gonna excel at sports and including
cheerleading you know hmm that was your
real opportunity and sure there were
other things that you could excel at but
he was kind of those were all
extracurricular you know I feel like
it's just a different time I asked you
know to me it wasn't the pressure of I
had pretty much come to the conclusion
that Locke wasn't gonna do sports I mean
cuz he was in my mind kids who are
really good at things these days they
start you know bright when they're
barely walking I was like this sports
aren't gonna be Locke's thing he's gonna
be into something else and this kind of
things have just sort of turned out that
way that he's
under this but uh to me I think the the
what's important is I'm just finding
something that they can excel at like if
it involves practicing and putting time
into something and then seeing a result
if kids aren't doing something like that
you know and your kids are doing like
piano lessons and colored and all that
other stuff you know oh yeah all that
other stuff but yeah I I you know I feel
like our experience and where we are now
in our careers certainly has impacted
the way that we want to help enable our
kids to discover who they are at an
earlier age you know we just kind of
backed our way into it a lot of course
everything we do none of it the paradigm
for it didn't exist well beyond just
being entertainers or filmmakers when we
were middle school in high school but
you know that's the thing I want to
instill in my kids is self-expression
and understanding yourself and having an
opportunity to explore things and fail
you know to find the one thing that you
succeed at so maybe we should just
invent a new sport you know maybe that's
what it is you know maybe it's a sport
where you wear pants like you know
that's part of it you have to wear pants
just call it pants pants the sport and
it's just how quickly you can get on the
most number of pants okay
or you could just you could just be the
art of wearing pants and it's not a
sport it's just like walk around smiling
oh yeah that's true maybe maybe that
team wants to be a model I feel about
that feel great about it
good-looking guy they make lots of Bank
and they get free clothes you know you
walked right off that runway and just
keep going you keep close you know
technically that's not true yeah I know
technically they're not seductive all
right but I'm saying if you just kept
walking your goodies steal steal steal
the key a thief so that's really the
moral of the story today kids is if
you're a model you should steal the
clothes and parents you know we don't
envy you because we are one of you and
it's not easy but you know
we screw it up and just don't tell
anybody yes and I would say you don't
have to talk at length like we do about
it and yeah show your hand you really
can't I mean can you really get if
you've got the best intentions and
you're in your care about the welfare of
your kids can you really screw it up
that bad
it's just like you think a caveman
raised kids man Kate but they were cave
kids in fairness you know they you know
they're they're using words like hawk
their etiquette around the cave was just
embarrassing but I mean they've been
doing it for you know hundreds of
thousands of years and you know it's
it's not that big of a deal so I think
that we'll be talking to somewhere
besides each each of us and the next
year biscuit yeah hopefully but there
will be other ones where we're talking
to you so if you want to give us
feedback on this your biscuit please do
and if you want to hear us talk about
something else
specifically where's that comment they
could comment on this sound SoundCloud
would be a good place or you could do
that on iTunes
yeah but tweet at us and let us know
hashtag ear biscuits that's really the
best way leaving a review on iTunes is
fabulous and really helps us you can
comment along with SoundCloud
thanks again for hanging out and as we
went down memory lane I started with
underwear around my underwear place and
now they're in my hand here they are
right here and I'm gonna put them in a
box like I'm not have his underwear I'm
gonna keep him for years in my hand do
some it's a metaphor he's not really
holding his underwear
[Music]
[Music]